körperliche vierte Advent ganz im
Zeichen des Krieges in der Ukraine und
es gibt keine Hoffnung auf einen
Weihnachtsfrieden im Gegenteil gerade in
dieser Woche gab es besonders schwere
Raketenangriffe durch Russland die
Menschen in der Ukraine haben harte
Monate vor sich sprechen wir über diesen
Winter und über das was der Westen
weiter tun kann und dazu begrüße ich
diese Gäste bei uns ist Roman gonzerenko
er ist ukrainischer Journalist und
Leiter der osteuropa-redaktion der
Deutschen Welle er hat seine Familie aus
der Ukraine nach Bonn geholt und ich
begrüße Olivia kortasch sie ist deutsch
polnische Journalistin von 2018 bis 2021
war sie freie korrespondente in Warschau
und in den letzten Monaten hat sie aus
der Ukraine berichtet herzlich
willkommen Erik Kirschbaum freier
Journalist aus den USA und der dort
schreibt der vor allem für die Los
Angeles herzlich willkommen Thomas Meyer
er ist leitender Redakteur bei der
österreichischen Zeitung Standard für EU
und NATO in Brüssel und sie kennen sich
wie immer beteiligen über Facebook und
weiter und natürlich auch anrufen die
Ukraine versucht mühsam das Leben
aufrecht zu erhalten ein Teil der
Stromversorgung konnte ja wieder
hergestellt werden aber von einer
Normalität ist man sehr weit entfernt
Jens Eberl fasst zusammen
Stromausfall mitten während einer
Operation in Kiew die Ärzte müssen sich
mit Taschenlampen behelfen Russlands
Angriffe ziehen auf die ukrainische
Infrastruktur oft fehlt es an Strom
Heizung und Wasser und das zu Beginn des
Winters
vor zehn Monaten am 24 februar beginnt
die russische Invasion und damit ein
Jahr voller neuer Krisen Roche während
die USA der Ukraine immer mehr
Milliarden an militärhten Zusagen
herrscht in Europa immer wieder
Uneinigkeit wie man der Ukraine helfen
kann
Verstimmungen auch am Donnerstag auf dem
EU-Gipfel in Brüssel am Ende beschließen
die EU-Regierungschefs neue
Milliardenhilfen für die Ukraine nachdem
ihnen der ukrainische präsidenzki ins
Gewissen geredet hat
zeigen sie Führungsstärke der erste der
Moderne Panzer schickt wird das damit
auch dem Rest der Welt ermöglichen und
er wird in Erinnerung bleiben als einer
der größten Verteidiger der Freiheit
unserer Zeit
nun warten neue Herausforderungen der
Ukraine stehen harte kalte Monate bevor
putinskrieg gegen die Ukraine wird der
Winter zur Waffe
herr Meier ich würde gerne mit ihnen
beginnen wir haben es gesehen der
EU-Gipfel in dieser Woche hat sich
erstmal etwas schwer getan mithilfen für
die Ukraine und selensky hat noch mal
ins Gewissen geredet hat zeigen sie
Führungsstärke zeigt die EU genug
Führungsstärke
das ist eine Frage die man mit ja und
mit Nein beantworten kann was ich beim
Gipfel gezeigt hat ist dass die Europäer
einerseits schwach sind sie brauchen
immer viel zu lange sie verlieren sich
im Kleinen mit veto-drohungen
wechselseitigen und so weiter aber sie
können sich dann im letzten Moment doch
immer auf wichtige Dinge einigen das war
jetzt beim letzten EU-Gipfel im Brüssel
die Hilfe für die Ukraine 18 Milliarden
Euro die aus dem EU-Budget frei gemacht
werden für Hilfe aller Art also sowohl
humanitär als auch militärisch die
Schwäche zeigt sich dass man sich wieder
einmal in Energie Fragen nicht geeinigt
hat nach Monate langem Streit eine der
Kernfragen in diesem Konflikt das wurde
verschoben von den Chefs von den Staaten
Regierungschefs weiter delegiert wieder
zu den energieministern die darüber
setzt September verhandeln und sie sehen
schon wenn Regierungschefs sich nicht
einigen können wie sollen das dann die
Energieminister lösen es geht hier nicht
um technische Fragen es geht vor allem
eine politische Frage und politische
Entscheidungen und da muss man leider
sagen ist Deutschland auch voran
Deutschland ist der größte Bremser in
diesem Zusammenhang da kommen wir
vielleicht in den Details noch darauf
aber das ist natürlich nicht
Führungsstärke die man in einer
Kriegssituation braucht die Aussichten
sind nicht sehr optimistisch wir sind
nach einem Jahr können wir jetzt sagen
mit dem ersten Eroberungskrieg in Europa
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg konfrontiert
und die Antwort die die Europäer darauf
geben müssten sollte eigentlich stärker
ausfallen das tut sie aber leider nicht
wenn wir das hören dass es nicht genug
ist sagt Herr Meier was würden Sie sagen
was sagen die Menschen in der Ukraine
sie waren viele unterwegs in den letzten
Wochen dort ist es genau das was die
Menschen dort von der EU wollen mehr
Stärke und letztendlich dann auch mehr
Waffen das brauchen Menschen ich meine
momentan geht die Menschen überall im
Land nicht sehr gut es ist Winter das
ist auch das Thema dass wir heute
besprechen werden und alle leiden
darunter und wenn man dann fragt welche
Unterstützung wünscht ihr euch hier dann
wird als erstes Waffen werden es ist
Waffen genannt tatsächlich wollen die
Menschen dort mehr Unterstützung gesehen
und es ist glaube ich auch also momentan
wissen wir Deutschland liefert
verglichen mit anderen Ländern haben die
DVP gemessen am Inlandsprodukt gemessen
sehr sehr wenig in der Masse ist es viel
wenn man nur die sich die nette Zahlen
anguckt klar das ist macht auch einen
Unterschied in der Ukraine aber in der
Ukraine selbst wird das so gesehen dass
Deutschland nicht liefern will und ich
glaube das ist das ähm ja größte
Versagen ja die Leute und vor Ort wollen
mehr Hilfe wollen wir Unterstützung und
zeigen deswegen auch dass sie dort aus
haben wollen dass sie aushalten wollen
damit ja damit sie einfach bestehen
können Sie wissen um was sie kämpfen der
Renker wie sehen sie sind das Waffen
dieser Moment am meisten gebraucht
werden wir haben ja wir hören ja gerade
sehr stark von der Zerstörung der
Infrastruktur ich habe so anfangs gesagt
ihre Familie ist hier aber sie haben
natürlich viel Kontakt in die Ukraine
was brauchen die Menschen dort
die Menschen brauchen natürlich war für
das ist da muss ich völlig zustimmen
zunächst kurz eine kurze Ergänzung ich
habe keine Leitungsposition sondern bin
Redakteurin der Hauptabteilung Osteuropa
mit dem Schwerpunkt Russland und Ukraine
zurück zu fragen die Menschen brauchen
zwei Sachen erstens Waffen zweitens
Waffen und drittens auch Waffen und
danach kommen natürlich Generatoren und
genau das ist das von womit ich mich
jetzt privat beschäftigt habe vor kurzem
gerade eben habe ich die Nachricht
erhalten dass die Generatoren wir haben
Spenden gesammelt auch einige Kollegen
haben sich beteiligt vielen Dank an alle
die sind jetzt gerade angekommen in
einem Krankenhaus in der Zentrale
Ukraine und das ist eine große Freude
aber zurück noch mal zu Ihrer Frage
welche Waffen braucht man die Ukraine
bekommt sehr viele Waffe nun immer mehr
wir haben diesen Krieg schon seit fast
einem Jahr aber das ist immer noch nicht
genug es ist gerade ausreichend um den
russischen Vormarsch zu stoppen und
kleinere Gebiete vielleicht in zwei
Fällen größere Gebiete im Osten
im Norden bei hakiv im September und
jetzt vor kurzem internationen im Süden
zu befreien aber um mehr zu befreien
weiter vorzurücken und noch mehr
ukrainisches Land zurückzuerobern dafür
braucht ihr Ukraine schwere
panzerkampfpanzer Leopard 2 in erster
Linie aber auch
anderes Gerät das heißt das ist das was
ich von meinen Bekannten von fremden
Leuten noch keine als erstes hören wenn
ich frage was braucht ihr bitte schick
uns Leopard 2 okay Kirschbaum die
Amerikaner liefen natürlich auch Waffen
es geht jetzt aber auch konkret wir
haben das ja gesehen in dieser Woche
konnten viele Raketen auch verhindert
werden die einzige verhindert werden
durch Raketenabwehrsysteme da gibt's ja
auch eine Diskussion in den USA wie viel
ist die USA bereitet noch zu tun
haben viel Waffen geliefert und tun es
immer noch und tun das ganz gern ich war
bei einem Empfang bei Amy Cutman in
Berlin vor ein paar Tagen und sie hat
das ganz klar gesagt dass die Ukraine
kämpfen für unsere Freiheit auch jetzt
und das finde ich auch könnte man in
Deutschland mehr hören das geht um
unsere Freiheit hier in Deutschland auch
was die Ukraine machen und wie alle
gesagt haben ja Waffenlieferung ist
wichtig es ist was Ukraine will dass du
keine braucht und es macht bisher den
Unterschied in den Krieger aber wenn man
wenn man tagtäglich sieht ähm die
zivilistische
die angetroffen werden die Sturm die
Wasserlieferung ich würde denken in
Deutschland würde das Meer mehr
Ärger mehr Frust hervorrufen die
Deutschen werden wissen frustrierte und
und mehr tun wollen um Ukraine zu helfen
um das zu verhindern Deutschland könnte
mehr machen eine Menge mehr machen mit
Luft
Abwehrsysteme und bisher war Deutschland
zögerlich 14 zögerlich Erklärung dafür
sind in Deutschland leben passt das muss
sie denken dass passivismus sind die
Antwort für alle Probleme der Welt
leider ist es nicht so und ich hätte
gedacht denn sie zehn Monaten die
Deutschen würden sehen das passivismus
nicht die Antwort für alle Probleme ist
eine starke Beteiligung hätte dass
vielleicht verhindern können aber
Deutschland hat ja also hat seine Hilfe
erhöht ganz stark
formulieren ich glaube es ist nicht
sinnvoll dass jetzt nur über Deutschland
diskutieren wir müssen über alle
europäischen Staaten und das sind 27 wo
die Polen z.B eine eine hervorragende
Rolle spielen also vorbildlich sozusagen
auch in der humanitären Hilfe vor allem
jetzt hat der Kollege gesagt Waffen
Waffen ja das stimmt aber unser Thema
heute ist eigentlich Winterkrieg es geht
um Energie es geht darum dass Millionen
von Menschen überleben müssen und ich
glaube wir sollten das schon ein
bisschen ausgewogen sehen mit ihrem
Hilfe es sind die Europäer die viel mehr
Hilfe leisten als die USA zum Beispiel
und das ist genauso wichtig wie alles
andere
können sie aber ich stand zum Beispiel
an so einem kritischen
infrastrukturobjekt in hakiv als eine
Rakete auf uns zugeflogen kam und die
wurde abgeschossen so und dieses ja das
war sehr sehr wichtig dieses Objekt um
eben die ganze Region hakiv und die
Stadt große Teile der Stadt mit Energie
zu versorgen und die war schon teilweise
zerstört also ich glaube klar man muss
man nicht eine Hilfe leisten aber aber
dennoch kann man das nicht loslösen
wissen Sie denn wenn man keine Waffen
liefert und wenn man eben keine
Möglichkeit gibt sich zu werden dann
dann kann man ja dann sehen
das sagen wollte ist das Gebot der
Stunde ist wir müssen Energie liefern
wir müssen
humanitäre Hilfe leisten Nahrungsmittel
Medikamente und so weiter Krankenhäuser
ersetzen das ist im Moment notwendig
dass man jetzt schon anfängt damit also
es ist auch eine Diskussion Winterkrieg
mit vielen
Opfern wahrscheinlich
was macht das jetzt so schwierig
besonders im Winter wenn man jetzt auch
auf die Armeen schaut man mal auf die
russische Armee und auf die ukrainische
sind die überhaupt gerüstet um im Winter
eben weiter zu kämpfen und es wird ja
dann auch schon jetzt schon von einer
möglichen Großoffensive noch mal für
Januar Februar gesprochen ja einige
haben erwartet dass jetzt in diesem
Winter zu einem Stellungskrieg kommt
weil es eben sehr kalt ist und dass die
Wetterbedingungen nicht immer für eine
große Offensive passen ich bin da etwas
skeptisch also ich glaube Russland
könnte versuchen eine offensive
durchzuführen aber nicht sofort sondern
vielleicht im Januar Februar da sagt
auch der Ukraine sagen auch keine
generelle
aber hat sich
generalstoffchef hat sich dazu geäußert
vor kurzem auch andere Russland könnte
das auch versuchen das heißt ich gehe
nicht davon aus dass es in
Stellungskrieg wird
aber sie haben gefragt wie sind die
Armeen darauf vorbereitet die russische
Armee das hören wir ist etwas schlechter
darauf vorbereitet weil es gerade eine
Mobilisierung durchgeführt hat die jetzt
abgeschlossen wurde aber einige sagen
und ich stehe mit dem auch so die wird
auch ein bisschen versteckt weiterlaufen
vielleicht kommt dann eine zweite oder
eine dritte Welle denn es reicht nicht
momentan Russland versuchte die nicht
nur die Front zu stabilisieren sondern
auch demnächst eine offensive
vorzubereiten vielleicht mehrere
offensiven aber momentan gibt es
Berichte das Russland Schwierigkeiten
weiterhin mit der Versorgung hat aber es
ist gelungen auf jeden Fall Russland die
Frauen und mehr oder weniger zu
stabilisieren jetzt in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten vielleicht auf der
ukrainische Seite versucht man diese
Stadt bachmut im Osten der Ukraine wo
momentan die heftigsten Kämpfe sind
keine Präsident selenski in beschreiben
das als Hölle und das ist wörtlich zu
nehmen da wird wirklich jede Sekunde
geschossen mit schwerem Gerät das ist
Feuer und das ist furchtbar was da
passiert
russland versucht diese Stadt
einzunehmen das ist strategisch wichtig
um weiter dann Richtung Westen
vorzurücken auf die Städte wie kam es
rausgekommen z.B und für die Ukraine ist
das extrem wichtig äh dieses diese Stadt
zu halten
da wird sich jetzt wahrscheinlich die
größere Schlacht weiter
sich fortsetzen aber danach was danach
passiert ich glaube Russland überlegen
sich weiterhin von Berau Belarus aus vom
Norden noch mal die Ukraine anzugreifen
die Ukraine sagt wir sind relativ gut
vorbereitet aber Russland hat weiterhin
deutlich mehr Kriegsgeräte momentan
natürlich ist der Verschleiß sehr groß
aber es geht weiterhin erwarte nicht
dass der Krieg sehr bald zu Ende ist
wie sehr halten die Menschen das noch
durch jetzt ist der Winter fängt erst an
und wenn man denkt Januar Februar wenn
es noch mal kälter wird wenn es weiter
keinen Strom gibt all das was ist ihr
Eindruck wird es eine stärkere ja
Fluchtbewegung geben oder sagen die
Leute hinein wir müssen jetzt hier
bleiben die internationale Organisation
für Migration hat glaube ich kürzlich
eine Umfrage gemacht und daraus ging ja
vor dass man da 90% der Menschen die
noch vor Ort sind nicht weggehen möchten
ich erlebe das auch so mit Freunden und
Bekannten die beispielsweise in Kiel
Leben und jetzt auch in alten Wohnungen
ohne Wasser und ohne Stromversorgung
leben müssen die sagen wir müssen
bleiben weil wir müssen mitleiden
die haben noch die Möglichkeit
Alternativen zu suchen die können
vielleicht auch in den Westen gehen die
können sich kleine Häuser mieten am
Lande der Stadt und dort Holzöfen
betreiben aber die meisten Menschen die
dort geblieben sind vor allem im Osten
im Süden wo die Situation am
schlechtesten ist können nicht weg wir
reden von alten Menschen Rentnerinnen
und Rentnern die in den elften Stock
hochlaufen müssen weil die Aufzüge nicht
funktionieren die Kanister voller Wasser
holen müssen stundenlang anstehen müssen
in der Kälte bei Minusgraden und das
nach oben tragen müssen und das ist ein
Beispiel von sehr sehr vielen ich meine
es geht auch weiter mit Geburtskliniken
oder Kinderkrankenhäusern die Angst
haben müssen dass der Strom ausfällt und
die Generatoren reichen momentan einfach
nicht aus also egal wo man hinsieht
es ist sehr sehr hart und ehrlich gesagt
weiß ich nicht wie die Menschen das
ohnehin jetzt auch schon aushalten
können also es ist unvorstellbar
wirklich was man dort sieht deswegen
wieder zurück kommt nach Deutschland und
dann die Debatte westlicher ja
Führungsköpfe und Regierungspolitiker
mitbekommt dann wirkt es ein bisschen
losgelöst von der Realität die Ukraine
momentan hat also ich spreche vom
französischen Präsidenten und und auch
von unserem Kanzler Scholz hier momentan
teilweise ist es ja es wird ein bisschen
absurd wenn man wenn man eben dann die
Forderung nach Frieden und nach
Gesprächen
hört ja es gibt hier eine Frage bei
Facebook Peter Ohlinger fragt warum
strebt man schon der Bewohner der
Ukraine zu Liebe keine
Friedensverhandlungen an und dann schaut
man ja auch immer gerne in die USA
Kirschbaum und sagt ja wenn die USA die
könnten das doch irgendwie anstreben an
andere zu machen
ja aber Frieden ist nicht immer die
Antwort ich glaube man kann Ukraine
nicht ein freem diktieren wo die wissen
wohl dass die wussten nutzen eine
Feuerpause um den nächsten Kriegs
vorzubereiten und deswegen auch noch
schlimmer und die Amerikaner wollen dann
nicht reinmischen und Ukraine ist
irgendwas zwingen was die nicht bereit
sind ich glaube solensky Regierung weiß
ganz genau was die wussten vorher haben
und das ein Frieden Einstein
Waffenstillstand wirklich so ihren
ungünsten wäre und das war überhaupt
nichts lösen der nächste Queen kommt
Stillstand schon ja aber es waren auf
die Ukraine hören ich meine 20-14 hat
diese Krieg begonnen Deutschland hat
weggeschaut hat Deutschland dann nur
Stream 2 belohnt Russland belohnt mit
der eine eine Belohnung für die
Übernahme von Grimm und so sieht man es
gab die Deutschen sollen sich bisschen
raushalten weil die Deutschen denken nur
passivismus nur ein Frieden und das ist
nicht die Antwort die Ukraine momentan
helfen will ich glaube schon auf die
Ukraine und was die sagen aber
raushalten und gleichzeitig unterstützen
ist ja schwierig unterstützen mit Hilfe
mit Lieferung die die gewünscht sind wie
Deutschland das tun könnte Deutschland
baut wunderbare Waffen ist eine der
größte Waffenexporteur der Welt in der
ganze Welt schickt Deutschland diese
Hightech Waffen warum könnte nicht mehr
an Ukraine schneller liefern herr Meyer
wie sehen sie es gibt eine Chance dass
man sagt Deutschland muss eine stärkere
Rolle nehmen
Opfer von oder aus Deutschland spielt
eine sehr passive Rolle eigentlich bis
jetzt das war von Anfang an so wo Scholz
ist nicht entscheiden konnte aber
welchen Weg gehen soll ist die Koalition
hatte Probleme
also von Deutschland sehe ich keine
große Offensive Frankreich ist ja
pessimistisch wir haben macron gesehen
beim Gipfel er hat gesagt
ich weiß nicht mehr wörtlich was
sinngemäß wir müssen uns auf ein sehr
hartes Jahr 2023 Einstellen der Krieg
wird mit unverminderter Härte
weitergehen und es wird vor allem darum
gehen unser Energieproblem also jetzt
von der europäischen Sicht aus zu
bewältigen das heißt natürlich umgekehrt
da gebe ich Ihnen vollkommen recht die
Situation in der Ukraine ist ist
grauenhaft also ich bin da eher nicht
sehr optimistisch wir müssen uns glaube
ich darauf einstellen dass es Millionen
von Flüchtlingen gibt ein Aspekte oft
unterschätzt wird und das will ich
vorher gemeint mit humanitärer Hilfe die
Flüchtlinge kommen ja nicht nur zu uns
nach Deutschland nach Polen das gibt
auch Millionen von bienenflüchtlingen im
Land selbst die Leute sind hilflos man
muss ihnen helfen in jeder Hinsicht mit
Nahrungsmittel mit Unterkunft mit
Elektrizität und so weiter also diese
Illusion von Friedensverhandlungen die
ist da aber ich halte das auch für ein
bisschen naiv ich glaube wir müssen uns
darauf einstellen dass es in Februar das
ist aber sehr bald in einigen Wochen zu
einer Verschärfung der Lage kommt
silenski sagt das auch sehr deutlich im
Economist in einem Interview das
erschienen ist und das ist glaube ich
die Realität mit der wir uns
auseinandersetzen müssen auf jeden Fall
was in Richtung verschärfen auch
hindeutet oder ich interpretiert oder so
das sind diese Meldungen dass die USA
jetzt doch vielleicht der Ukraine
patreon Systeme liefern können
Luftabwehrsysteme man hat sich bis jetzt
dagegen entschieden aus Angst das
Russland als rote Linie interpretieren
könnte jetzt ist es so von beiden
Gespräch und das ist für mich indirekt
ein äh ein Signal möglicherweise kommt
etwas eine neue Offensive Russland es
gibt berichtete dafür darüber besorgt
sich
ballistische Raketen im Iran
es kann noch weitere Angriffe damit
machen und diese Systeme könnten helfen
sie können sie nicht ergänzen darf heute
hier Putin in Belarus in Weißrussland
das sind keine guten Anzeichen also es
gibt schon die Befürchtung dass als
nächstes Land Weißrussland direkt
hineingezogen wird in Weltkrieg warum er
wenig das dann sind wir von der Grenze
her auch schon bei Polen direkt also es
braut sich hier sozusagen eine ein
Szenario zusammen wo wir Europäer zwar
nicht im Krieg beteiligt sind aber wo
uns das immer näher rückt ohne jeden
Zweifel und das ist die Aussicht auf das
Frühjahr die wir in Angriff nehmen
müssen und wir können ja nicht träumen
von Friedensverhandlungen in diesem
Zusammenhang habe ich das gemeint putin
will diesen Frieden nicht dass er der
deutsche Kanzler auch sehr deutlich im
Bundestag gesagt er will erobern er
schlicht und einfach mit allen Mitteln
dazu passt auch eine Bemerkung von Jan
fröhlich bei Facebook er sagt wer
erklärt Deutschland und Frankreich dass
sie europäischer und solidarischer
werden müssen um auch selbst besser
geschützt zu sein als Abschied von
nationalen allein Gängen gegenüber
Russland und vielleicht auch noch dazu
bei Twitter fehlt in Deutschland nicht
ein Minister oder sogar der Kanzler der
sich offensiv für mehr militärische
Hilfe einsetzt also immer wieder
dasselbe Thema dass wir halt eben das
vielleicht dieses ganze Thema des
Krieges noch nicht so angekommen ist wie
würden sie sehen aus wenn jetzt was was
jetzt geplant ist für den für Januar
Februar all die Drohungen wie sieht man
das in Polen also was man in Polen vor
allem sieht ist dass der deutsche
Kanzler mit Wladimir Putin telefoniert
was man sieht ist ein
Interview und der Süddeutschen Zeitung
dass er erst gestern erschienen ist es
wurde heute schon diskutiert im
polnischen Medien dass Deutschland
weiterhin besonnen
agieren will und keine Alleingänge
machen möchte und ich glaube man
vermisst da so ein bisschen die
Führungsrolle den Anspruch den in
Deutschland lange hatte auch weil es so
eine große industination ist und seine
wirtschaftliche Macht einfach auch hat
also das das sieht man auf jeden Fall
man wünscht sich glaube ich mehr
Führungsanspruch des Nachbarlandes Polen
versucht das selbst ein bisschen
auszufüllen schon seit Monaten und
schafft das relativ gut kann aber das
nicht so liefern wie wie Deutschland
natürlich auch wenn man z.B mit in
Frankreich ist und mit beratendes
Präsidenten spricht da existiert
polnische Politik sehr häufig einfach
nicht es ist einfach so also diese diese
Achse es ist immer noch zwischen Paris
und und Berlin und ich glaube als also
der polnische Konsens ist wirklich dass
man sich dann ein bisschen mehr bisschen
näher wünscht aber
Polen erstmal dann die Hilfen nicht
geben wollte in der EU Herr mai
vielleicht noch ganz kurz dazu bevor wir
zu weit über lange Reden
der Süddeutschen erwähnt ich habe es
heute früh beim Frühstück gelesen es ist
eine ganze Seite ist ein wirklich langes
langes Interview Europa kommt in diesem
ganzen langen Text überhaupt nicht vor
er sagt nur einmal wir werden keine
Eingänge machen keine deutschen Eingänge
aber er hat überhaupt keine Idee wie das
gesamt europäisch laufen kann und das
finde ich sehr bemerkenswert jetzt im im
kritischen Sinne weil natürlich auch die
deutsch-französische Achse im Moment in
dem zusammen und nicht funktioniert da
ist ziemlich tote Hose zwischen Paris
und Berlin und das sind natürlich keine
guten Zeichen wie man damit umgeht zu
Polen wollte ich noch sagen das ist mir
auch ganz wichtig es gab eigentlich in
den letzten zehn Jahren immer seine
gewisse ich sage jetzt mal westliche
Arroganz gegenüber osteuropäischen
Nachbarn und jetzt hat sich
herausgestellt die Balken die Polen die
Osteuropäer die haben Putin und die
Entwicklung in Russland viel besser
gelesen ja und weil sie recht gehabt
haben und die kommissionspräsidentin von
der Leyen hat das im Parlament in
Straßburg im September bei ihrer redet
solange Union auch deutlich gesagt sie
hat sich so entschuldigt bei den
Osteuropäern für diese Ignoranz die wir
hatten ich glaube auch diese ganze
Debatte die wir ständig über
Waffenlieferungen
hat auch die Vorurteile und Stereotype
die der besten gegenüber der Ukraine hat
lange auch gegenüber Polen hatte als als
Polin in Deutschland aufwächst kann ich
das auch also sagen man hat da glaube
ich ein bisschen ein besseres Feingefühl
auch fürs es gibt immer noch immer
wieder in diesen Debatten hört man die
können unsere Waffensysteme gar nicht
bedienen
man kann Patriot ähm Waffensysteme kann
man innerhalb von zwei drei Monaten
erlernen so dass es geht um wie viel wie
lange ist der Krieg schon am laufen und
das sind eben dieses dieses
paternalistische dieses die können das
aber vielleicht gar nicht oder was
machen die mit den Waffen die wir
liefern was machen die damit können wir
den Vertrauen also ich finde das
entblößt wirklich eher das westliche
Denken als als dass es irgendwie zeigt
was in der Ukraine gerade die Regierung
und die Frage ist ja wenn wir denn jetzt
noch mal auf den Boden der Tatsachen auf
diesen schrecklichen Winter schauen wenn
wir schauen was den Leuten jetzt was sie
jetzt wirklich brauchen dann haben wir
eigentlich keine Zeit noch langfristig
zu überlegen sondern brauchen ja ganz
schnell hilfe wie ist das was brauchen
sie jetzt im Moment wo würden Sie sagen
wir haben gehört in kie werden
Wärmestuben aufgemacht es gab dann ein
bisschen ein Streit zwischen Klitschko
und silenski das gesagt wurde sind nicht
genug werbestuben das also wie ist das
Land irgendwie darauf vorbereitet also
das Land ist relativ gut aus meiner
Sicht darauf vorbereitet denn der kriegt
er auch schon sehr sehr lange und man
hatte vorher auch das vorausgesehen das
was jetzt kommt deshalb ist es aus
meiner Sicht ähm keine Katastrophe
natürlich ist es der härteste Winterzeit
um Menschen Unabhängigkeit keine Frage
und es wird vielleicht noch härter
kommen aber die Ukraine wird das
schaffen die Menschen sind bereit sie
sind sehr gut organisiert und man hört
wie wie mit wahnsinniger Geschwindigkeit
die ukrainischen Elektriker also die
Stromversorger jetzt das
Wiederherstellen was Russland kaputt
macht das ist wirklich eine heldenhafte
Leistung das höre ich von Experte aber
ich höre das wohl nichts werden wie
schnell das passiert und natürlich
leiden die Menschen die brauchen alles
was irgendwie Strom erzeugen kann keine
Frage der Westen Sicherheit jetzt Gott
sei Dank ganz viel die Europäische Union
liefert auch Deutschland liefert viele
liefern und es ist nie genug das ist
genauso wie bei Waffen das Ausmaß das
muss man sich immer vorstellen das ist
ein sehr sehr großes Land viel größer
als Deutschland größer als Frankreich
das zweitgrößte flächenmäßig Land in
Europa die Entfernungen sind sehr sehr
groß das sind hunderte Kilometer und das
ist eine große Herausforderung aber das
schaffen die Menschen wenn sie wissen
dass diese Hilfe auch weiter kommt und
das ist genau sehr wichtig denn doch
irgendwo eine langfristige Strategie
genau sie müssen wissen dass dass die
Hilfe wir hören das immer wieder von
Politikern und das wird beim G7 Gipfel
gesagt bei anderen Gipfeln wir
unterstützen die Ukraine so lange wie
nötig aber manchmal kommen doch bei der
Ukraine Zweifel denn man hört wie wie
die Menschen hier auch auf die Straßen
gehen wenn weil die Preise weil die
Inflation und es gibt jetzt nicht genug
Gas und alle retten jetzt was passiert
im Januar wenn die Rechnungen kommen was
dann und die Ukraine möchte sicher sein
dass dann die Hilfe nicht weniger wird
es wird mehr gebraucht es gibt eine
Untersuchung vom Mercator Forum
Migration und Demokratie eine
jahresstudio da heißt es nur noch 40
Prozent der Europäer finden dass ihr
Land trotz eigener negativer
wirtschaftlicher und sozialer folgen die
Ukraine weiter uneingeschränkt
unterstützen wollte das ist nicht
besonders hoch wie ist es in den USA
Kirschbaum ist wie stark ist dieser
Krieg überhaupt in den USA Präsident ja
den Medien ist es nicht so präsent aber
ich glaube die Amerikaner im großen
Ganzen bewundern die Ukraine und die
wissen die bestehen das ist ein Kampf um
Freiheit gibt und nicht nur Freiheit
sondern für uns alle und deswegen ist
die Unterstützung glaube ich in den USA
schon einiges höher als hier in Europa
und ich höre das hier immer wieder in
Deutschland die stöhnen über die
Energiepreis sind die inzwischen wieder
gesunken sind übrigens und die Sterne
über die Kosten und ob das uns mehr
schade dass hilft und so weiter und
sofort es geht wirklich um die Freiheit
Ukraine es gibt wirklich kaum was
richtiges aus dass du verteidigen und
ähm manchmal habe ich schon Angst wenn
ich in Deutschland äh das hör auf
Ostdeutschland die die Verständnis für
Russland die Einkreisung diese diese
Legende von der NATO einkreisungen ich
denke hey guck mal was passiert das ist
alles eine Legende und Puten spielt
drauf Puten hofft dass die Europäer die
Westeuropäer langsam keine Lust mehr
haben werden und die freut sich mal die
hohen
Energiepreise wären sind bestimmende für
unser Handeln als das Mitleid mit den
Ukraine oder der Idee dass man der
Ukraine im Sinne der westlichen Freiheit
helfen muss ja genau die Deutschen
werden vielleicht nicht so lange mit
market wohnen Puten weiß das der hat
sich für rechnet mit dem Krieg überhaupt
und die Deutschen sind immer noch nicht
bei zwei Prozent Bruder immer ins
Produkt für ihre Verteidigung
versprechen vor acht Jahren ist immer
noch nicht dafür das ist Putin sich
wirklich verrechnet weil er gesagt er
ist da schneller aber langfristig herr
Meier es scheint ja da sehr wohl ein
langen Atem zu geben wenn man jetzt am
an das Ende des Winters schon denkt und
sagt da kommt vielleicht eine große
Familie dazu sagen ich finde es total
interessant dass die Kollegen zuletzt
gesagt haben
zu diesen Umfragen was die Unterstützung
der Ukraine betrifft es gibt eine vom
europäischen Statistikamt europarometer
eine relativ neue Umfrage die im Januar
dann voll publiziert werden wird und
dort zeigt sich was ganz was
interessantes drei Viertel der Europäer
insgesamt gesehen unterstützen
die die Haltung dass man der Ukraine
hilft dass man die militärisch hilft
humanitär und so weiter aber interessant
ist wie sich das zwischen den Ländern
aufteilt die Unterstützung ist zum
Beispiel eine nordischen Ländern in in
den Benelux-Ländern bei den Osteuropäern
bei über 90 Prozent
in Deutschland und auch im Land wo ich
her kann man in Österreich ist das ganz
anders hier leistet man sich seit
Monaten öffentliche Diskussionen und
nicht vielleicht doch die Amerikaner
schuld sind an diesem Krieg und nicht
doch Putin da irgendwie hineingelegt
worden ist und so weiter also ganz
seltsame Diskussionen in einer Situation
wenn ein eroberungskrieger Putin ein
Land mit 40 Millionen Einwohnern ganz
offensichtlich mit allen Mitteln zu
brechen versucht und das sehen wir
zuletzt indem man nicht militärische
Ziele angreift sondern Strom
Wasserversorgung so weiter zerstört das
heißt hier ist glaube ich und dass das
würde ich sehr unterstützen was
herrschenko gesagt hat es geht nicht um
Waffenlieferungen nicht nur um
Hilfsmittel es geht vor allem ich will
es mal sagen um eine mentalitätsmäßig
eine geistige Unterstützung die wir den
Ukrainer liefern müssen ich meine man
muss sich das mal vorstellen welcher
Situation diese Menschen leben und
tatsächlich geht es natürlich um
Freiheit um Demokratie die Ukrainer sind
wahnsinnig motiviert weil sie frei sein
wollen sie wollen einen freien
demokratischen Land leben und das
möglichst auch irgendwann mal innerhalb
Europäischen Union so wie wir auch und
ich habe manchmal den Eindruck dass wir
vor allem hier im Westen sehr sehr
genauisiert ja vor allem die reichen
Länder in erster Linie Angst in den
eigenen Wohlstand haben und wir jammern
darüber dass die Büros jetzt noch 19
Grad haben statt 21 und solche Dinge
wenn man dann die Bilder sieht und die
berichtet die ein paar hundert Kilometer
östlich von Wien sage ich mal ganz
bewusst sich abspielen dann fragt man
sich eigentlich manchmal vor allem wenn
man so wie ich in Brüssel lebt und dass
es einen großen Ferne ansieht was ist
hier eigentlich los auf diesem Kontinent
da haben wir noch nicht wirklich
realisiert dass wir in einer der größten
Umbrüche Leben wahrscheinlich seit 1989
oder überhaupt 1945 hier steht nicht nur
ein bisschen was auf dem Spiel sondern
möglicherweise die ganze Zukunft der
Freiheit der Demokratie und auch das
vorstellen dass der Wirtschaft in ganz
Europa die Frage wie präsent das eben
wirklich ist es gab ja die die Bitte von
oder die das Angebot von selensky dass
er heute beim WM Endspiel eine
Friedensbotschaft ausbringt das hat die
FIFA nicht erlaubt jetzt mal unabhängig
von der Frage ob das politisch so
richtig ist oder nicht aber die Frage
Herr konstanto wie präsent ist dieser
Krieg und wäre das ein gutes Zeichen
gewesen in dem Sinne noch mal klar zu
machen das was er Maja sagt wie sehr es
uns alle angeht das sprechen Sie einen
sehr wichtigen Punkte an ich
auch diese Umfragen und eigentlich meine
ich das ist normal dass die
Unterstützung oder Zustimmung etwas
sinkt der kriegt dauert schon so lange
das ist eine sehr schwere psychische
Belastung für viele Menschen und dann
kann ich jeden Tag gleich sagen oh Gott
oh Gott oh Gott was machen wir jetzt
aber die Unterstützung könnte auch höher
sein aus meiner Sicht vor allem in
Deutschland da gebe ich Ihnen Recht und
ich habe viele Erklärungen dafür die
deutsche Geschichte natürlich der DDR
und das alles also das Verhältnis West
aus Deutschland das ist alles klar
müssen wir nicht lange darüber
diskutieren aber wo ich bei uns
Journalisten und Medien denn Vorwurf
mache ist vielleicht sind wir zu sanft
geworden was diesen Krieg anbetrifft
denn
wir zeigen aus guten Gründen sehr wenig
Bilder die wirklich diesen Klick
vermitteln ja wir verpixeln die ganz
schlimmen Bilder oder wird zeigen sie
gar nicht und aus meiner Sicht muss man
diese Bilder sehen denn so sieht der
Krieg aus sonst ist es sehr schwer in
einer warmen Stube hier okay die Preise
steigen aber das ist immer noch Frieden
hier und
sich vorzustellen was für ein
grauenhafter Krieg dort passiert diese
Brutalität und das ist das was mich auch
überrascht ich hatte zuletzt mehrere
Gespräche auch mit Militärs hier im
Westen oder auch mit Experten mit
Politikern und oft viel das Wort wir
haben es uns nicht vorstellen können
dass dieser Krieg so brutal sein kann
das Russland so brutal sein kann hier
mitten in Europa und da frage ich mich
wieso denn eigentlich nicht russland hat
in Tschetschenien Kriege geführt in den
90er Jahren russland hat in
Georgienkrieg geführt in Syrien geführt
warum hat man jetzt etwas anderes
erwartet das ist die Art russische Art
Krieg zu führen brutal mit ganz viel
Artillerie ohne Rücksicht auf zivile
Verluste und trotzdem ist man überrascht
ja und das könnte halt eben alles viel
härter werden jetzt noch mal im Winter
ich glaube wo ich ihn nicht zustimme ist
diese Ermüdungserscheinungen denn ähm
wenn man z.B nach nach Polen sieht dort
sind die Menschen auch müde also
warschau hat sich komplett verändert in
den vergangenen paar Monaten dort ist
der Immobilienmarkt zu Real das ist
nicht vergleichbar nicht mal mit mehr
mit mit Berlin aber trotzdem ist es
einfach ein anderer glaube ich dort
sicherheitspolitische Ansatz als
beispielsweise in Deutschland und ich
glaube da unterscheidet man sich sehr
stark das ist dieser
sicherheitspolitische Ansatz ist dass
man in Polen denkt man setzt auf einen
Partner USA und man kann in der Zukunft
auch noch drauf bauen und in Deutschland
denkt man eher wahrscheinlich ändert
sich die Regierung bald in in den USA
und wir können eben dann nicht mehr
darauf hoffen dass uns die USA stark
unterstützen ich glaube dadurch spiegelt
sich halt vor allem diese also nicht die
Ermüdungserscheinung weil ich glaube die
ist überall in Europa gleich sondern
dort wo der Ansatz politisch politisch
liegt und wieder seit Monaten eben
gesteuert wird
insofern ein Sonderfall weil es ganz nah
dran ist ja wohl ist viel mehr als
Deutschland dran und dadurch ist auch
das Bewusstsein was da passiert viel
viel höher als in Deutschland dass sie
sagen Deutschland ist nicht zu nah dran
aus also wenn sie von Portugal
ausschauen oder von Paris ausschauen ist
Deutschland eigentlich dran bei der
Ukraine und vor allem auch bei Polen und
dem ganzen Raum also ich denke mir wenn
ich auf alle europäischen Länder schaue
und was ich auch eingangs gesagt habe es
hat sich praktisch alles geändert wir
leben in einer anderen Kontinent ein
Jahr nach nach Beginn dieses Krieges
schauen Sie nach Finnland und Schweden
wenn sie wenn wir hier vor einem Jahr
gesessen werden und ich hätte gesagt sie
werden sehen die werden bald der NATO
beitreten dann hätten sie mich
wahrscheinlich wie verrückt erklärt wenn
ich gesagt hätte sie werden sehen dass
Polen und Ungarn gar nicht auf einer
Linie sind ja sondern die Polen sind
anders als Viktor Orban ja dann hätte
man mir das wahrscheinlich nicht
geglaubt und trotzdem also
ja klar ist schon klar aber das sind
ganze Bilder riesige
Perspektiven die sich verändert haben
nur Deutschland das wollte ich sagen
scheint sich überhaupt nicht zu ändern
und auch nicht bewegen zu wollen in
Deutschland gibt man sich offenbar noch
immer Illusion hin das wird schon wieder
irgendwie und dann werden wir unseren
Wohlstand weiter ausweiten und das ist
glaube ich eine große Illusion ich sage
nur drei Namen Schröder Merkel
Steinmeier das sind die drei führenden
deutschen Politiker die die europäische
Russlandpolitik die erdgaspolitik die
Energiepolitik in den letzten 20 Jahren
in Europa bestimmt haben ich sehe bis
heute noch keinen richtigen Ansatz dass
man mal selbst kritisch das hinterfragt
und sagt es war ein riesiger Fehler Nord
Stream 2 zu entscheiden noch bis zur
letzten verteidigen war ein riesiger
strategischer Fehler der Bundespräsident
Steinmeier muss ich sagen hat das glaube
ich gemacht aber es ist aus der Sicht
der europäischen Partner auch sehr
erstaunlich wie deutschen sich da
verhält bis hin zuletzt zu dieser 200
Milliarden Hilfe für
Unternehmen und und Privatpersonen das
sind Summen die sind für andere Länder
unvorstellbar und die haben natürlich
Angst dass Deutschland hier einen
eigenen Weg geht und die europäischen
Partner völlig links liegen lässt und
die in einem Punkt möchte ich Ihnen ganz
kurz widersprechen Deutschland bewegen
sich schon und ich beobachte dieses Land
seit über 20 Jahren wir haben am Anfang
des Jahres noch kurz vor dem Krieg eine
totale Verweigerung erlebt der
Bundesregierung die ganz neu war muss
man auch Rücksicht drauf nehmen neue
Konstellation
wir liefern nicht und dann hieß das wir
liefern 5000 Helme dann
kleinere Waffen und dann wurde immer
mehr immer mehr und zum Schluss hat
Deutschland jetzt Iris dieses Thema
modernste Systeme geliefert die dann
sehr effektiv bis heute sind und für die
Kirche unendlich da und dankbar ist das
muss man anerkennen in Deutschland ist
einfach sehr langsam ausgegeben sich
viel zu langsam und die Kritik ist
berechtigt aber Deutschland verändert
die sind wirklich lang die sind objektiv
lang das muss man einfach akzeptieren
verschiedene Veränderungen Kirschbaum
wie würden Sie denn in diesem Licht das
Verhältnis zu den USA sehen Frau Konzert
eben noch mal darüber gesprochen wenn
dann vielleicht ein neuer Präsident
kommt also das wäre ja jetzt eigentlich
noch mal so ein Punkt wo man sagt
mussten wir ganz schnell jetzt Dinge mit
den USA gemeinsam auf den Weg bringen
also wie würden sie das Verhältnis
gerade beschreiben zwischen USA EU und
Deutschland ja ich meine neue Präsident
kann kommen aber es kann noch Präsident
beiden sein noch sechs Jahren das ist
nur Spekulation
wieder gewährt zu werden und ähm ich
glaube die amerikanische Politik will
auch nicht so gewählt ändern es gibt
auch in der republikanische Partei auch
viele unterstütze für Ukraine und vieles
viel republikanische skeptisch sind ich
sehe keine große Änderung Phase seine
neue Regierung gebe und das könnte
wirklich in sexy ja der Fall sein die
mehr kann es in die bewundern Ukraine
wirklich es ist ein hirtenhafte Leute
und es wird viel darüber berichtet wie
wie die kämpfen da in der Kälte wie die
Landwirte schnell die elektrischen Strom
nehmen wieder ans Netz gebracht werden
sind es gibt schon viel viel
Bewunderungen in den USA wie wie
zwischen EU und USA wird natürlich jetzt
auch belastet jetzt durch diese ganze
Energiekrise durch das durch den
Inflation reduction Act also das
Subventionsprogramm für amerikanische
Unternehmen also kann das nicht auch
dann ja die beiden Mächte der
auseinander bringen ich glaube nicht ich
glaube wir probieren zusammenzuarbeiten
Lösungen zu finden wo es Probleme gibt
ich glaube die Amerikaner von die beiden
Regierung weiß wie wichtig äh die EU ist
vor allem Schiene gegenüber und beiden
hat so viel wieder gekettet hier mit
Deutschland und Europa diese Situation
vor dem Ukraine kriegt die beiden
Regierung und blinken haben die
europäische zusammengebracht wie ich
kaum in meinem Leben gesehen haben die
Europäer sind wirklich eine eine Einheit
gewesen gegenüber Russland die wollen
auf diesem wunderbar vorbereitet die
Sanktionen haben zwischen 9 und
Sanktionen und das ist auch kein
Verdienst von beiden und blinken ich
glaube ein Shampoo ich weiß nicht ob die
das auch zustande gebracht hätten das
ist ja ein Punkt auch die EU hat ja auch
gehalten es hätte ja auch sein können
dass durch diesen Krieg die EU sich viel
stärker spüren glaube ich vollkommen
Recht
die EU-Kommission und die europäischen
Institutionen haben da auch eine gewisse
Rolle gespielt wenn wir jetzt
zurückblicken ist es ja ganz erstaunlich
dass die erste Runde der Sanktionen
unmittelbar nach Kriegsbeginn schon
begonnen hat das war nur deswegen
möglich ich habe das gestern extra noch
mal nach recherchiert weil die
Kommission im Geheimen schon im Herbst
begonnen hatte im Grund im Prinzip diese
Sanktionen vorzubereiten das wurde nicht
an die große Glocke gehängt aber es gab
ja natürlich auch den USA vor allem
Geheimdienst berichtete dass sie sich
ein Krieg zusammenbraut ich war beim im
März wird glaub zwei drei Wochen nach
Kriegsbeginn und noch dazu im Gastein im
spiegelzahl haben die europäischen
staatsregierungschefs getagt 100 Jahre
nach der Neuordnung nach dem Ersten
Weltkrieg das war ein bisschen bezahlt
weil man gespürt hat wie groß die
Verunsicherung beim Europäern ist man
wusste nicht weiter und das sind und da
hat man sich sehr sehr schnell mit
beiden und den USA zusammengeschaltet
und beiden hat hier eine führende Rolle
übernommen es dann auch zum NATO-Gipfel
nach nach Brüssel geflogen also das
stimmt also wenn es hart auf hart geht
dann klappt das auch irgendwie ja
innerhalb des Bündnisses aber es ist wie
wir schon eingangs gesagt haben immer
ein bisschen zu spät und ein bisschen zu
wenig
zustimmen darüber haben wir noch gar
nicht gesprochen natürlich findet
gleichzeitig ein globales Match statt
China Indien Russland USA Europa und ich
glaube dass dieser Krieg auf einer ganz
anderen Ebene dass sie mir noch nicht
dazu führen wird dass die Demokratie in
dieser Welt ja und das sind eben die
Amerikaner die kanadische Europäer sich
verteidigen müssen gegen die Autokraten
und Diktaturen in dieser Welt die
unserer Gesellschaft unserer
Gesellschaftsmodell ablehnen und
zerstören wollen dafür steht Putin und
diese diese Auseinandersetzung findet
statt und ich merke das auch im Brüssel
das Amerikaner und Europäer sich auf
dieser Ebene immer immer gut
verständigen kann dass das größere
globale picture Bild sozusagen
wichtig ist so eine triebfederin ist
dann um meine Eltern
wir müssen jetzt endlich Weiterkommen
als Gemeinschaft dieses kleinstaatliche
nationalstaatliche damit kommen wir
nicht weiter wir sind Dir die haben kein
Gewicht ist selbst Frankreich und
Deutschland die groß sind
sehen sie da irgendwie ein paar
Anzeichen für das ist
gut die wusste schon Waffensysteme sind
geschwächtnis aus Iran Drohnen holen
weil die keine Chips kriegen mehr ich
glaube ich Sanktionen spielen immer mehr
ein Gewicht und das wird je länger der
Krieg dauert desto schwieriger wird für
Russland sein die die Waffen zu bedienen
die brauchen und die Systeme und so und
so die Sanktionen man kann das leicht
kritisieren die sind nicht so hilfreich
aber ich glaube schon langfristig und
die werden immer stärker und die
Europäer gehen in die gleiche Richtung
aber Anfang war ja auch glaube ich die
Angst dass jeder EU statt für sich
selbst Energie klar macht und alle und
das gar nicht teilt und ich glaube das
davon sind wir sind wir auch nicht
angekommen dass jeder nur egoistisch auf
sich selbst geguckt hat sondern ich
glaube innerhalb der der EU hat man da
auch große Fortschritte inzwischen genau
ist man da glaube ich also ist auch
glaube ich weniger schlimm als man am
Anfang befürchtet hat dass das alle in
die nationalistische Schiene abdriften
worauf muss man sich einstellen in
diesem Krieg Herr grundscharenker wie
lang denken sie wird dieser Krieg noch
dauern ich glaube der Krieg wird noch
sehr lange dauern
meine Perspektive zwischen zwei und zehn
Jahren also vielleicht irgendwo
dazwischen denn russland zeigt überhaupt
keine Anzeichen nachgeben zu wollen das
hat Präsident Putin mehrmals deutlich
gemacht auch vor wenigen Tagen sein
Pressesprecher Russland hält an seinen
maximilen fest und diese Ziele lauten
ein Großteil der Ukraine inklusive
Hauptstadt möchte die Russland erobern
unterwerfen
Regierungswechsel und dann weitere
aktionsgebiete das heißt das was wir
jetzt im Herbst gesehen haben vier
Gebiete der Ukraine annektiert wurden
das möchte Ausland weiter so machen das
heißt wir müssen uns darauf einstellen
aber die Ukraine in seinem eigenen Land
dafür die Unterstützung bleibt es wächst
zwar Unzufriedenheit wegen der
Mobilisierung aber die hält sich in
Grenzen das kann er noch aussitzen und
erhofft darauf dass er längerfristig
noch gewinnen kann er kann nicht mehr
zurück und alles was er sagt oder tut
geht in die Richtung er bereitet sich
auf weitere Versuche noch mehr
ukrainisches Land zu erobern das heißt
das ist das worauf wir uns auch
einstellen müssen
was denken Sie Frau kottas wie lange
dieser Krieg noch denken noch dauern
wird ich
stimme da leider zu ich glaube dass das
noch sehr sehr lange anhalten wird ich
meine man sieht auch durch diese
teilmobilisierung wurde der der Russland
wurde diesem Land auch eine große
wirtschaftsmöglichkeit und eine Kraft
weggenommen also die Prioritäten hat mir
Putin sind Eindeutigkeit die man von
Anfang an klar und werden sich auch
nicht ändern ja da stimme ich Ihnen zu
ich sehe das im Prinzip genauso ich bin
mir aber nicht so sicher
ob die Ukraine in der Lage sein wird
diesen Druck stand zu halten es scheint
so zu sein das Putin mit allen Mitteln
und das meine ich wörtlich diesen Krieg
gewinnen will er hat 150.000 Soldaten
mobilisiert die jetzt gerade ausgebildet
werden die er offensichtlich bereits in
den Tod zu schicken also da fürchte ich
im Jahr 2023 das sagt sie lensky auch im
Economist wie ich schon erwähnt habe in
den nächsten Monaten wird eine sehr
entscheidende Phase eintreten wenn das
überwunden wird da gebe ich Ihnen recht
dann wird das wahrscheinlich ein ganz
langer fürchterlicher
Stillstand sein im Kriegszustand die
Frage ist welche Schlüsse ziehen wir
daraus jetzt schließlich wieder anderen
das was ich mit Europa meine wir müssen
glaube ich viel stärker werden was
Solidarität zusammenrücken Gemeinschaft
gemeinschaftliches Handeln betrifft wir
müssen wegkommen von diesen kleinlichen
nationalistischen Interessen die da
immer die uns Bremsen wo man sich
wechselseitig jemand an die Füße tritt
das wird eine Herausforderung werden ich
sag das jetzt nicht die realistisch
unsere Sendung noch mal anzuknüpfen ob
der Winter noch eine Waffe wird
letztendlich ist denken Sie das ist eine
da ist Putin letztendlich ja dann doch
der Stärkere weil er nein er versucht es
er versucht das aber er scheitern damit
er wird damit scheitern weil die Ukraine
resistente sind als er denkt und weil
der Westen hilft lassen Sie mich noch
ändern der mir am wichtigsten erscheint
ich glaube das meine ich durchaus ernst
mindestens so wichtig wie Waffen und und
finanzielle Hilfe und zahlungshilfe und
so weiter ist der menschliche Faktor das
was Menschen füreinander tun das ist in
der Ukraine so es ist bewundernswert
wenn man schaut wie die Menschen sich
dort aushelfen und wie die im wahrsten
Sinn des Wortes jeden Tag überleben
müssen aber es ist mindestens so wichtig
dass bei uns ja die Zivilgesellschaft ja
die die vielen Hilfsorganisation und so
weiter die flüchtlingsbetreuung und so
weiter das muss funktionieren ich glaube
das ist das allerwichtigste auch für die
ukrainischen für die Menschen in der
Ukraine selbst dass sie das Gefühl haben
die Franzosen die Italiener die Polen
die lassen uns nicht im Stich das ist
unbezahlbar eigentlich wie denkt man in
den USA darüber wird das noch lange
dauern ja es kann schon lange dauern
aber das ist ein Dynamik aber ich glaube
in der Westen einig bleibt und
Deutschland mehr hilft die Hilfe rollt
jetzt wenn es weitere world dann wird
Usern auf keinen Fall diesen Krieg
gewinnen wahrscheinlich demnächst
verlieren wichtig ist dass Deutschland
Hilft und ähm nicht diese Ideen hat die
die Deutschen die die wussten aufgeben
und wird schnell verlieren diese Idee
muss weg sein und Ukraine kann den Krieg
gewinnen es gibt eine Frage von Claudia
Dingen bei Twitter sie fragt deshalb
sollte man nicht durch strengere
Sanktionen gegen den Iran dafür dass im
Iran endlich das Regime stürzt und
dadurch keine Waffen mehr in Russland
geliefert werden weil das ist ja auch
ähm entsetzlich die Entwicklungen im
Iran
sind schon sehr alt gegen Iran ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass die noch
härter werden können die Waren Krieg
keine Computerteile quick gar nichts aus
dem Ausland ja die leiden seit
Jahrzehnten Unterstützung
ich würde gerne einen Anrufer mal dazu
holen nämlich Hans-jürgen Bauer aus
Troisdorf
schönen guten Tag
Schatz als mal gewesen oder ich glaube
dass dieser Krieg so wie er geführt wird
und auch weitergeführt werden wird
meines Erachtens
eine packsituation ist
Russland wird alles hineinwerfen was es
gibt der Westen wird alles und die
beschleunigen Menschen auf beiden Seiten
für mich persönlich mein Ansatz ist und
dass ich eine Frage an sie würde es
nicht besser
zügelt
darin hineingesteckt wird
völkerung Russland geht denn es ist ja
kein Staat das ist ein es ist ein
korruptes ein verbrecherisches System
das tut ihm aufgebaut hat und kein Staat
mehr dass wir das hier auf allen Wegen
dieses irgendwie gibt der russischen
Bevölkerung klarmachen
worum es geht und wer was tun und der
Typ kann meines Erachtens nur beendet
werden du Russland selber durch die
Russen und nicht durch immer
fortführende Waffenlieferungen die noch
und Totschlag bedeuten vielen Dank Herr
Bauer für ihre für ihren Anrufe würde
ich gerne damit mit diese Frage an Sie
gehen ob man mit viel Geld in Russland
erklären kann das Putin ein Verbrecher
ist und einen verbrecherischen Krieg
führt das versuchen viele Medien im
Ausland auch unsere Redaktion bei der
Deutschen Welle versucht durch
objektive Berichterstattung zu erklären
was passiert ist nur muss man auch
realistisch bleiben ganz viele Russen
und Russinnen unterstützen Putin
weiterhin egal was man im Westen darüber
sagt sie sind einfach
sie finden das was er macht toll sie
finden diese Träume von Groß Russland
und Wiederherstellung des Imperiums
wunderbar das ist ein harter Kern das
sind nur vielleicht bis zu 20% alle
anderen sind passiv relativ passiv die
passionierten sind entweder jetzt
geflüchtet vor Mobilisierung oder wurden
eingesperrt
Oppositionelle ermordet oder eingesperrt
das heißt durch allein durch im ideale
Berichterstattung da einen Wechsel oder
Veränderung zu herbeizuführen ist sehr
optimistisch was nicht heißt dass wir
das nicht versuchen sollen das heißt
versuchen weiterhin objektiv zu
berichten denn es wird dieser Krieg im
Kern dieses Krieges ist eine Lüge ganz
viel Lüge über den Westen aber die
Ukraine und so weiter
aber das ist ein anderes Thema okay ich
würde gerne Frau Astrid Peters dazu
holen Astrid Peters aus Berlin schönen
guten Tag Frau Petersen ja ich grüße Sie
ganz herzlich ich bin 84 Jahre alt ich
habe den Krieg noch miterlebt und ich
wollte dazu sagen wenn die wenn
Deutschland und Frankreich nicht
verhindert hätten dass die Ukraine die
NATO kommt wäre es meiner Meinung nach
nicht zu diesem Krieg gekommen denn ich
glaube nicht dass Putin mit der NATO
kriegt angefangen hätte und ähm ich
finde wenn diese beiden Länder sich so
verhalten haben dann müssen diese beiden
Länder mein Land und auf Frankreich
dafür Sorge tragen dass die Ukraine
nicht zwei drei vier oder zehn Jahre
Krieg führen muss dann ist ja von der
Ukraine nichts mehr da ich meine was
soll denn dieser Blödsinn das heißt wir
sind ein Land
hat ihre Botschaft ganz klar gemacht man
hätte die Ukraine Leonardo aufnehmen
sollen ja wie geht man da jetzt weiter
um weil ist das ein ist das ein Punkt wo
man sagt ja das war ein großer Fehler
es ist in der Nachbetrachtung bei
historischen Dingen immer ein bisschen
schwierig zu sagen oder so gewesen
ich bin nicht sicher ob es realistisch
war dass die 2008 auf dieses Jahr spielt
ja die Dame an beim Nato-Gipfel
hat sich diese Frage gestellt und ich
denke nicht dass die Ukraine dann im
Blitz Verfahren sozusagen die NATO
aufgenommen worden wäre richtig ist ja
und das habe ich ja eingangs schon
erwähnt das vor allem Deutschland Merkel
aber auch Schröder vorher immer schon
eine artismen Politik gespielt hat auch
versucht hat selbst gegen jede Einsicht
nach der Ernährung kriegen das schon
erwähnt vorher hier Putin einmal auch
kritisch zu hinterfragen das ist wahr
aber könnte jetzt Frankreich und
Deutschland sozusagen dafür sorgen als
kriegsnationen um um die Ukraine zu
retten das ist natürlich vollkommen
irreal ich sag das ein Beispiel ich war
vor einigen Wochen habe ich eine
Diskussion unter jungen Franzosen ja
beobachtet da war die Frage wenn jetzt
tatsächlich wieder
die Situation eintreten sollte dass wir
zu den Waffen gehen müssen würden wir
das machen das sind Leute Anfang 20
junge von und die Jungen großen haben
gesagt ja würden wir machen und ich habe
mir dann gedacht das wäre eigentlich
wenn wir diese Diskussion in Deutschland
führen würden fragen Sie mal junge
Deutsche 23-Jährige ob sie bereits in
den Krieg zu gehen ich glaube das ist in
Deutschland eine der schwierigsten
Diskussionen die es überhaupt gibt es
auch Deutschland ist glaube ich nicht
kriegsfähig in dem Sinn ich kann mir das
schwer vorstellen und deswegen glaube
ich außerhalb der NATO ist das eine
Frage die nicht zu lösen ist von
Deutschland oder Frankreich noch eine
ganze Ergänzung ich halte es für einen
Fehler dass an dem NATO fest zu machen
dass erstens das war damals 2018 kein
Thema aber ganz wichtig vor einem Jahr
hat Russland mehrere Forderungen
aufgestellt an den Westen hat gesagt die
NATO soll bitte zurück auf die Linie 97
das heißt ihr Polen musste raus die
baltischen Staaten müssen raus und die
anderen das heißt es geht Russland nicht
um Ukraine beitreten es geht um viel
mehr es geht um eine neue Aufstellung in
Europa ich würde ganz gerne dazu passt
glaube ich michaelmann aus Bonn der auch
noch was was zur NATO fragen möchte Herr
Willmann
ja hallo guten Tag meine meine Meinung
ist ganz klar die NATO sollte
personell und materiell sowieso sich
viel stärker in der Ukraine gegen
Russland engagieren es ist ein Skandal
das der besten ihr zwar sehr viel Hilfe
leistet aber doch die Ukraine
militärisch
ehrlich ja
alleine lässt und zuschaut wie das ganze
Land von Russland von Putin Russland
zerstört wird das ist ein Skandal des
Westens und eine Schande für den Westen
ich plädiere für eine personelle und
sehr viel massivere Unterstützung der
Ukraine durch die Nato und hier vor
allem auch durch Deutschland okay
das ist angekommen das haben wir ja auch
schon besprochen ich würde sagen wir
lassen das mal kurz so stehen was
darüber haben
es ist wichtig zu verstehen die Ukraine
hat jetzt überlebt vor allem danke
westlichen Waffenlieferungen aus der USA
in erster Linie noch vor dem Einmarsch
zweiter Punkt der Western zöger die NATO
zögert weil Russland ständig mit Atom
Jahren droht darüber haben wir noch nie
gesprochen aber das ist ein Kern das
Problems denn diese Drohungen die
erzeugen natürlich und das hat auch der
Bundeskanzler Scholz mehrmals gesagt die
erzeugen natürlich Ängste auch in der
Bevölkerung auch in der Politik deshalb
ist man sehr vorsichtig vielleicht zu
vorsichtig ich halte diese Drohungen
Russlands für übertrieben deutlich
übertrieben ich glaube nicht an einen
Atomwaffeneinsatz in Ukraine nicht
tauche in Europa nicht aber trotzdem das
erzeugt diese Lähmung
der nächste Anrufe die nächste Anruferin
ist Gerd aus Berlin schönen guten Tag
ja einen schönen guten Tag
ihre Frage bitte
es geht darum ich höre immer wie wie
wenig Deutschland tut und ich bin der
Meinung geben Milliarden wir haben
gestern den die Sender gehabt ein Herz
für Kinder Klitschko war auch dabei es
sind
tausende und Millionen Geld geflossen
die Kinder haben gespendet alle haben
gespendet wir haben so viele Ukraine ich
habe viele Freunde die selber welche
aufgenommen haben ich glaube dass wir
wirklich in Deutschland und wo ich auch
sagen muss und das möchte ich gerne mehr
die Gründe Fragen tun wir nicht schon
alles und wir können nicht mehr Waffen
kriegen das müssen wir uns später mal
mit weil ich mit tupperwarte verteidigen
in unsere Bundeswehr hat ja auch kaum
noch was okay ja
eine Frage ist das Gericht so über
Deutschland laufend
vielen Dank Frau Gerhard sie sagen
Deutschland tut einfach schon wahnsinnig
viele von mir Deutschland oder eine
Menge eine Million Flüchtling ist nicht
aufgenommen wurden die die natürlich ist
enorm und gewaltig ist es nur die
deutsche Regierung hat einiges
Versprechungen gemacht und das noch
nicht erfüllt und deswegen ist
Deutschland ein bisschen auf der Prange
in dieser Hinsicht und Deutschland
könnte mit seiner Waffen viel mehr tun
ich hier auch an den kalten Kriegs Rocco
die Amerikaner so viel für Westberlin
und Westdeutschland gemacht hat diese
Solidarität für die Freiheit Deutschland
war ungebrochen und ich wünsche mir dass
die Deutschen ein bisschen mehr für die
Demokratie und die Freiheit zeigen
können das ist alles ich würde es gerne
ergänzen durch einen Punkt der auch in
Österreich übrigens sehr wichtig ist
weil sozusagen das was in der
öffentlichen Wahrnehmung in Medien
ankommt vielleicht nicht übereinstimmt
mit dem was sie wirklich im Leben
passiert ich glaube dass die die
Menschen viele Millionen Deutsche
einfache deutsche sehr sehr viel tun und
humanitärer Hilfe für Flüchtlinge und so
weiter aber die die am lautesten sind
eigentlich immer die die dann sagen die
Amerikaner sind Schuld wir sind Schulden
und so weiter also diese polarisierte
schrille Diskussion die sind
Öffentlichkeit gibt die entspricht
glaube ich nicht ganz im Bild das in der
breiten Masse der Bevölkerung besteht
außerhalb der Politik von Menschen die
sehr wohl bereits in anderen Menschen in
Not zu helfen umso mehr in einer
Kriegssituation und das schlägt sich
auch fragen wieder was anderes ist aber
natürlich bei uns
sozusagen die Ebene der Politik des
militärischen und so weiter das hat
natürlich mit Regierungen zu tun mit
riesigen Budgets und nicht mit dem was
einzelne Menschen Gott sei Dank an
humanitärer Hilfe leisten wenn sie
spenden wenn sie spenden geben
dazu passt glaube ich auch Volker Brüche
aus Grünstadt guten Tag Brüche hallo
guten Tag
wünsche ich noch ich habe eine ganz
kurze Frage ist eigentlich mit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg den Deutschen nicht
das Rückgrat gebrochen worden und sie
haben für alles keine Verantwortung mehr
übernommen das sieht man in Deutschland
mit Waffen will privat eine Waffen
sitzen dann wird es alles erschwert und
erschwert und erschwerden so gehen wir
überall in der Politik um wir liefern
schnell aber Verantwortung für unsere
Sachen übernehmen wir als deutschen
nicht
das ist meine Frage haben die Runde
warum und warum gibt es kein Druck mehr
von der EU ist ja die Frage ist das so
sie haben ja eben gesagt das ist
schwierig also wenn man solche sagt auf
Menschen
wurde von Nationalsozialismus befreit
das würde ich mal als erstes sagen und
das natürlich militärische Fragen in
Deutschland aufgrund der dieser
besonderen Vergangenheit in Europa
schwierig sind das ist ganz klar aber
ich denke eben dass wir jetzt genau in
dieser Zeit sind wo sich wo diese Fragen
alle neu zu stellen sind und es sind
vorab die Amerikaner eigentlich die uns
seit Jahren auffordern dass wir Europäer
viel mehr tun sollen für unsere eigene
Sicherheit und Verteidigung ja inklusive
Deutschland das muss man auch sehen und
ich glaube auch wichtig da ist das
Deutschland ziemlich schnell nach dem
Krieg auch ein Wirtschaftswunder hatte
und jetzt wirklich wirtschaftlich so
stark da steht wie kaum ein anderes Land
und und deswegen auch Verantwortung auch
übernehmen kann und ich glaube in
vergangenen Krisen auch stark übernommen
hat das ist vor allem diese Krise wo
Deutschland das nicht so auf sich nehmen
kann offenbar oder oder will vor allem
aber trotzdem die Erfahrung der Hilfe
gerade durch die Amerikaner nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg irgendwo gibt Punkte
da kommt es nicht an
ich weiß nicht ich denke nur die
Amerikaner haben aus dem zweiten Lehrer
in München 38 soll sich nie wieder holen
man soll keine peace mitmachen man soll
den Diktatur gleich bieten und das zu
verhindern dass es schlimmer wird und
ich glaube in Deutschland haben die
andere Lehrer aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
bekommen zum Beispiel nur passivismus
ist die Antwort für alles und ich
fürchte dass es nicht die Antwort jetzt
die Ukraine hilft eigentlich würde gerne
mit der Frage wie viel Hoffnung haben
Sie mit wie viel Hoffnung geben sie ja
auch in dieses Weihnachtsfest jetzt in
einer Woche ich habe ganz viel Hoffnung
denn es ist ganz anders gekommen als
Putin sie das ausgedacht hat und seine
generelle die den Krieg geplant haben
die Ukraine kämpfen sie werden nicht
aufgeben und nach allen Reisen jetzt
seit der Inversionen in die Ukraine habe
ich die Botschaft mitgebracht die
Ukraine wird gewinnen sie werden
weitermachen weiter kämpfen sie werden
in Dunkelheit sitzen sie werden frieren
aber viele Leute alle mit denen ich
gesprochen haben gesagt wir geben nicht
auf und das etwas mehr Hoffnung gibt und
was mir noch Hoffnung gibt ist die Hilfe
aus Deutschland hier wurde Deutschland
auch kritisiert ich finde Deutschland
könnte mehr tun aber wir sollen auch
anerkennen was genau gemacht wurde und
was noch kommt okay vielen Dank Herr
gonscharenker für dieses
Hoffnungszeichen am Ende dieser Sendung
vielen dank Ihnen hier für den
internationalen Frühschoppen Ihnen noch
einen schönen Sonntag hier bei Phoenix
alles Gute ihnen und eine gute
Weihnachtszeit tschüss
[Musik]
wir erleben Tage Wochen und Monate in
denen uns der Wert unserer
demokratischen Ordnung bewusst wird es
ist eine Zeit in der die Demokratie als
Ganzes durch Autokratien herausgefordert
und angegriffen wird und wir alle
aufgerufen sind für diese gefährdeten
Werte einzustehen blicken wir genauer
hinein in die autokratisch geführten
Gesellschaften erkennen wir die
Unterschiede zwischen unseren freien
Gesellschaft und einem totalitären
System Minderheitenschutz und
Minderheiten Förderung ist so ein
Unterschied und dem widmet sich das for